so fans of the show will know this it's
always been a dream of mine my number
one dream guest to have on this show is
Ryan Gosling I'm a big yeah big Gosling
fan want to get the Daddy Goss on the
Pete Holmes show I tried once I tried
calling him once we showed that on the
show I didn't go so well so we had to
try it again
here's what happened hey it's Ryan you
know the drill
hey Ryan it's a it's a Pete Holmes man I
I saw that you're directing a film now
you're a director that is so amazing and
you know we have a director on this
shown on the Pete Holmes show and I will
happily happily fire him do you get you
you see what I'm saying come direct my
show call me back okay hi you've reached
Pete leaving me see gcp I don't know how
you got my number but never call me
again I'm not interested in directing
you're selling a little show okay never
call me Ryan
OHP don't spit up some look something's
happened
an accident Stuart mmm blood help the
only one I get I'll be Ryan
Thank You Cole back I'll tell you
wherever now you get all they don't let
me die listen Peter I see what you're
doing you're trying to appeal to gosling
sense of empathy I know you're not hurt
because you're a terrible actor Pete
Holmes
you know how I know this because I'm a
great actor also a great person you know
because I help people and I break up
fight in Brooklyn
I've been to Muslim so many fights
they're unbelievable all right never
call me
hey Ryan it's Pete Holmes again you're
absolutely right that was a bad bad
performance you're right I need help
one of the reasons I'm calling you to
direct me anyway listen I want you to
know that I have a gift for you and it's
here at Warner Brothers stage 10 and I
don't want anything else I just want to
give you a gift it is wonderful you will
love it it is gorgeous it is beautiful
it is perfect it is a framed picture of
you who boy
come get it it's so good a joke P why
would I need a framed picture of myself
I already have a framed picture okay I
don't need presents my life's a present
my acting is a gift so call on me hey
Ryan
um I know you told me not to call you
back but I'm at a coffee bean and I ran
into your mother you're not gonna look
cool she actually she actually wants the
phone here you go it's your mother
oh it's me momma Gosling oh yeah we'll
just beat all the boys you be friends
with him here's the funny one you know
and you should register quite exciting
okay get in the [__] hello hey goodbye
but I see what you're doing here I can't
believe you would involve my mother
it didn't the fun laws and the real girl
Gosling okay this is place beyond the
pines unpleasant tattoos on my face
I'm distant but I'm appealing Oh
are you now ride away real fast on my
dirt bike up a dinky little ramp that my
friends from the woods system into his
truck and I throw up you know cuz you
can have a tough exterior but you know
be soft on the inside
like a waffle cake awesome tell my
mother saying hi